[Music]
be heavy
Tracy Chapman yeah right now open the
door
Tracy Chapman where is she right Tracy
Chapman Tracy Chapman's in my bed
tonight allegedly
I love Tracy Chapman Tracy Chapman if
you're listening and we know that you
are yes just know that we like you we
support you we know Luke Bryan Stole
Your Song and if we find Luke Bryan
we're gonna beat the [__] out of him
unless you paid him on site on site
unless you paid him to uh life since
that song yes so so where is she right
now is she still doing her Tracy Chapman
still tour because if so I'd like to get
tickets no that doesn't mean she's
touring they click on that said she will
tour again
we'll tour again
uh no unfortunately she's not I haven't
retired yet however at the moment there
are no plans for a tour I think it's
nice being not being on tour these days
it does take something away from
everyday life I appreciate being home
damn right but that was you Tracy that
was in 2015 years ago yeah so where is
she right now like I and I don't just
mean is she touring I mean where is she
right now Google where does Tracy
Chapman live if you get a chance but I
mean what's she doing let's send a hey
babe let's send a Kane Tanaka shirt to
her house
where she is she at the store is she
like on the bowl yeah you know is she is
she cooking is she that's every episode
try to find out where in the world is
Tracy Chapman where in the world is
crazy Chapman
she she has not releasing any original
music in 15 years well good for you
because I can't wait to do that let me
ask you a question name a second song by
Tracy Chapman Fast Car and uh uh baby
can I hold you
tuna in the right place in the right
time you be mine yeah fast car yeah go
fast car and then baby baby can I hold
you really are you making it up no look
here you have it I have it on my Spotify
how you doing that look here look how do
you know that look
baby can I hold you because
look at these two songs baby can I hold
you fast car on my Spotify and likes you
make that playlist or is that a curated
playlist that you just followed no I
make my own playlist oh you do [__] oh
so you added that yeah
my play would I listen I listen to back
to back I listen to Tracy Chapman and
Morgan Wallace Morgan Wallen back to
back I love it nah that's what I do back
to back for the people I think she has
the most covered song of all time every
country has borrowed fast cars does she
get paid for that that's hope so that
one hit right that's all she needed for
Life Google Tracy Chapman we should be
musicians because if you're a musician
and especially a solo act right maybe
not a band that has a one kid one she's
not really a one hit wonder I think
she's pretty steeped in it but whatever
but like if you have a song like that
that is just right that just transcends
everything right you if she's on the
licensing of that that's a done deal
that's done deal she's gonna make the
money in purpose that's right right they
have to license the the coverage Tracy
Chapman hasn't had any original music
since 2008 I haven't had original comedy
since 2013. I've just been stealing but
it's not the same here's the thing isn't
it more fun to be like isn't it better
to be a musician to make you to make you
bones because look you get one song you
tore off that you get residuals of that
if you own it for the rest of your life
and if it's a hit like that I mean I
know it's a one in a million shot but
number two you go to the concert and
they want to hear the songs they know
they're mad if they don't don't hear it
where so you don't have to be like well
if she's coming through I it better be
new music yeah it's like if she's coming
through it better be the old music it
better not be new music right that's the
thing I want to hear the old stuff where
with comedy we are the exact opposite
exactly if you hear the bit that I did
on this special if I did it at the show
you're gonna be disappointed and there's
no one joke that's gonna that's gonna
set us up for life even bird Chrysler
than me well bird Chrysler the machine
his special set him up for Life yeah
that that stand he could but that but
even that that's 20 minutes you still
have to give them another 50 minutes of
new stuff yeah but that like you gotta
jump off like that and you get that core
audience and they follow you and that's
right all right but no but I'm saying
that's Tracy I wonder what she's wearing
I was gonna say now that all the
musicians have to perform for tick tock
it has to go viral in Tick Tock or
you'll never get found that's not right
same with comedy too all the comedians
who have blown up it's because their
bits went viral on Tick Tock but it's
also they have to hire robots to get
plays on Spotify to get on the trending
list there's like a whole thing it kind
of sucks it's not it's not fun it's not
organic anymore it's not it's you have
to have the science behind it you have
to hire someone who knows now how to put
these clips up to beat the system and to
get into the algorithms it's it's it's
completely Beyond fun and Beyond what it
should be it's not like let me upload
something I have a I have a social media
account let me upload something to my
social media account and hopefully
people will find it if you're not paying
someone to to do like the behind the
scenes I have a question what was the
character cursed what was the first
rocket money viral video you remember
like watching on the internet
um shoes YouTube I have some shoes let's
get some shits really and get some shits
okay that was the first viral video 20
years ago just put shoes YouTube let's
get some shoes yeah this one let's get
you ever seen this I don't know can we
play it oh is that real is that not a
girl is it a guy in Drag
oh yeah this was when before drag was
yeah this is I remember watching this at
my friend who went to Mount Saint uh
Vincent's College and we were watching
in their dorm room dying laughing at
this
wait how long is this 16 years ago this
is the original one that's long yeah
this is this went viral this was viral
[Music]
shoes
I don't remember this because this is
before you this is before you other
something other was viral for you what
was the first viral thing for you what
have you thrown in what some of the
first viral videos what does it pull up
I think let's get something a few a few
of them if you pull them up I'll
remember them
oh I love this guy Star Wars because
I've never seen this one
oh it's so hot in here isn't it it's hot
in here you ever seen Star Wars kid
dancing baby yeah they had an Arrested
Development Star Wars kid is amazing
go watch it a ridge I've never seen Star
Wars let's actually scan these this
might be fun Star Wars can it's nice and
short
[Laughter]
wait wait it's not over yet
and you saw this in 2003 watch
yeah
[Laughter]
Now find the video they did somebody CGI
him all the guns laser guns coming in
and he's actually defending himself it's
the best it's amazing and they put the
music in the background it looks insane
my face on that making a tour now no you
gotta put kid in there though because he
thinks you're just another movie
I don't know if it's CGI but yeah yeah
yeah
this guy this kid is like now 40 and
he's somewhere
what
he looks like a genius man yeah
[Laughter]
what is what and was it an audition or
he was just filming himself it was
probably like in school like like to me
it looks like he's in the TV like audio
video club
or like he put it on like uh like like a
local access cable or some [__] the
dancing baby I vaguely remember so we
could skip yeah that I see that was Ally
McBeal right I don't know I don't even
know how you know Ally reveal
you've never seen that you ever seen
that I don't I don't think so the end of
the world 2003 never saw that
all your base are belonged to us no I've
never seen these badger badger I've
never seen any of these no a little
Llama Song
peanut butter jelly time I know
we like the moon no I don't know I've
never seen any of these
interesting
yeah I've never I've never um
I did not even get a computer in my
house like a computer in my household
till I was in college so like AOL and
all that I never I missed all of that I
didn't know I'm like six or eight years
older than you that's what I'm saying so
so you I 98 I had we had our first Acer
yeah I didn't get a computer till about
2004. okay I did not send my first I
swear to Christ I did not send an email
yeah I did not send an actual email to
anyone until 2009 was the very first
time I emailed anyone for any reason
that's late in comedy mine was like mine
was like 99. yeah you got we got a
desktop that was in the living room that
the whole family had to use in shifts
right and it was dial up right and I
remember when I was in college they
started talking about oh you can get a
college email assigned to you like St
john's.e that's how you got a Facebook
initially initially yeah you can only
have a college I wasn't in that but but
so then I was like my friends like oh
did you get an email address I was like
what are you doing he's like they'll
give you like your name at St John's and
then you could come in and you could
check the mail and I was like what do
you mean check mail he's like well other
people can write to you from theirs and
I was like well for what reason I was
like well just watching his girlfriend
used to date hadn't had one and so when
we were in the computer lab he go every
time we went to community lab class he
would sign in and then sign in and show
me that he got an email just one email
from his girlfriend yeah that just and
it was like just [__] like just like
you know what I mean yeah I'm like what
the point of this right just cursed
rocket money
um
and I was just I just couldn't really so
I was like I don't need one and I just
wasn't until a couple until AOL when
people started going in like the chat
rooms and [__] right like yeah I never
did now I never did a chat room I never
did like a chat roulette I just missed I
was very always I was the guy from the
beginning I always never wanted to be in
technology I know I got a Facebook only
when I started comedy I became a
physical therapist because I was like I
want to do something that you don't have
to know computers for I was very
anti-computer anti-digital for some
reason and I well now but we've had to
no but I think
exactly I think what's happened is I
went back to my roots now where I've
said to myself you know what even like I
think we were talking either off arrow
in the beginning of this episode of the
end of santinos about how now you need
people to run your socials and there's
an algorithm and then this and that my
brain automatically and I don't know
that it's a it's a fear of um or like
I'm just exhausted by it I don't even
want to try to tackle it it's that I
genuinely have no passion or interest in
I'd rather make less money and go less
far than just I'd rather go back to
physical therapy than have to get sucked
into that I really would because I just
don't I have zero zero
um want to even want to know how to
learn like like things that I get
passionate about you know they've been
saying they've been saying from the
beginning follow your passions babe
follow your passions whatever you're
passionate about so like I've lately
been reading books about things that I
just want to be passionate about and I
think you know if you try to force
yourself to learn something you don't
really care about it's never going to
come out the right way babe that's why
I've been learning about Roth IRAs have
you well if you learned I've been I've
been really taking a a deep dive into
Finance I got this book called Left
Brain Finance of right brain Finance for
Left Brain people okay it's like a
creative it's a it's like a it's like a
book that's written to explain Finance
to like a creative type that's actually
a great book what they say about Bitcoin
this I got this book 20 years ago but I
still have it and you haven't read one
page I thumbed it thumbed it yeah so
here let me tell you what I've been
doing yeah let me tell you what I've
been doing okay as as a little um
anybody who's um
whose parents out there even if you're
not a parent anybody who just feels like
they can't get their work done what I've
been doing and and it's something I did
not create this this is something that I
learned from shout out my man Ryan
Holiday from the daily stoic he sent uh
the daily dad book here for me uh he's a
fan of the Pod uh you know he's a fan of
you Sal Ryan holiday of the daily stoic
podcast it's a podcast I listen to every
day I read his books you listen to the
pot every day is it bite-sized bite size
which I think is the way to go when I
see 12 minutes I'm in I'm in when I see
two hours and 15 minutes I'm out that's
why I can't like it's it's it it's a lot
of people watch like Rising Rogan three
hours it's overwhelming for me I think
and write write email us at the what
about bite-sized hey babes what are you
guys thinking about 12 minute episodes
we put them out every day that looks
like an old Shane Gillis right there
that does that does the Ocean Gate it
rides the ribs us yes this this is about
the the thing okay but bite-sized hey
babes let us know what you think about
it write it in the community board
YouTubers hey babe gmail.com
what bite size hey babes that might be
the way here we go but what I've been
doing
what what I've been doing it no that was
a funny headline it said no regrets I
divorced my husband while he wallowed in
pity and killed my vibe
he's dying of a disease and this woman
said I'm divorcing him because he's
wallowing in self-pity and he's killing
her vibe get it girl work it
when you go sit down for like
arbitration and they're like what are
you filing for is it like Mutual you
know they say oh irreconcilable
differences she's like no he killed my
body he killed my Mitch Duncan so what
I've been doing and this is why I
shouted out Ryan holiday and this daily
stoic book and and the one that I'm
reading the daily dad but you can do it
with all his books they're designed for
this I believe is the daily dad is one
piece of parenting advice a day so
whatever the date is you go and wherever
you buy the book you start at that date
and then it's 365 lessons right and so I
wake up every day at 5am because my kids
the the baby wakes up at 5 45 so so so
no matter what you know you're waking up
at 5 45 like that's that is the time you
go down
it depends like tonight tonight you know
I got spots and won't go down till you
know 12 12 30 but last night didn't have
spots 9 p.m passed out in the middle of
a Woody Allen movie okay and and so so
passed out so I still do get myself
you're up at 5 45 when you get home at
12 31. if you have to you have to you
know but so so I I try to to limit that
but you know how our careers are if we
got late shows we got late show nothing
to do babe gotta put I gotta put food on
the table right okay even though
doordash can put food on the table and
if you go ahead and use that promo code
hey babe you get a nice discount yeah
okay and that they'll bring you that
food or you can make your own food
that's hella precious America's number
one meal kit so we got other places to
put food on the table they can act like
your kids daddies so but what I do is I
wake up now I set my alarm for 4 50.
okay wake up watch my face brush my
teeth quick I go down at five I've been
delaying having coffee I have a big gulp
of water big sip of water now you're
getting up early now you you're making
your window bigger that you can't eat
when you're awake well that gassed out
but I'm not even thinking about that I'm
thinking about I drink my big gulp of
water get the systems flowing and Andrew
huberman the Great neuroscientist you've
probably seen them all over right Andrew
humerman
he's everywhere lately the huberman he's
like and and so what he says and I don't
I think it's ad in his own it's a it's a
chemical that if you drink coffee too
early then you kind of don't let your
bodies like natural stimulants work it
kind of suppresses them so I delay my
coffee about an hour and a half it's
difficult but I do it but what I but the
reason why I'm getting to this is
because what I've been doing what I've
said to myself and I've been doing this
for the last three weeks is I read one
that daily dad page just to get the flow
going into reading and then I read I try
I say you're going to read 10 pages of
whatever book you've wanted to read so
the book that I'm eating right now is is
uh it's called the simple path to simple
journey to wealth or something it's like
portion control yes for reading but what
winds up happening is because I say the
first the for me my buzzer my alarm is
the first cry from the baby saying mommy
daddy then I know close the book your
time is done now it's typically 540 five
once in a while it's 5 20 once a while
it's 6 30. so I say the minimum is 10
pages I try to get 10 pages unless you
know she wakes up early but typically
it's closer to 20 Pages sometimes 30
pages and I am flying through books this
way because you'll read I'll read 500
pages sometimes consistently though
because it's consistent because that's
all I'm doing is rather than trying to
read one whole book on a plane ride are
you digesting 10 pages at a time yes
because I'm reading it I'm taking notes
underlining stuff and then what I
typically do it's in rocket money I use
it I like it it saves me money it goes
and you cancels All The Unwanted
subscriptions that you forgot about it's
literally awesome and it alerts you to a
change in your spending habits or
subscriptions that you know that it
looks out for you I I genuinely have it
it tells me each month where my spending
is based on last month if I'm above or
below and it's an awesome two the thing
I like about is how easy it is because
if you are going to cancel subscriptions
or try to you know uh track your budget
and spending on other apps you gotta do
them one by one yeah
you look at me like all right let me try
it I couldn't believe it you just put in
your email address that's it whatever
email address you have you put it in or
your number and it goes and it searches
and Aggregates all the places that you
have descriptions and then you hit one
button to cancel it it's the most genius
thing over three million people have
used rocket money saving the average
person 720 a year and right now all you
got to do is go to rocketmoney.com hey
babe that's
rocketmoney.com hey babe manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com hey babe stop throwing
your money away and cancel these
unwanted subscriptions babe guess what I
got a brand new hour of stand-up
material I'm gonna be doing the special
in Atlanta in December those tickets are
on sale soon but come see it before I
film it we got the Borgata in August we
got Radio City sold out in New York so
we added the theater at MSG September
23rd still some tickies available for
that we've announced Irvine California
Portland Seattle Las Vegas Omaha
Nebraska Kansas City Missouri St Louis
Missouri Hammond Indiana Pittsburgh
Detroit Columbus New Haven Connecticut
Providence Salt Lake City we're coming
to you baby with more being added soon
christycomedy.com for tikiwickies I hope
you guys are going to really like this
hour I think it's my best work come see
it we have a good time in the front row
if you buy tickets for the front row
I'll give you a kiss on the lips and a
bag of my pubes
hello guys and I just want to give you
some dates right now the very last
weekend of the Joker's tour for now the
first leg is happening July 27th uh 28th
and 29th we're at Nashville at the Grand
Ole Opry Cambridge field house uh in
Indianapolis and the stifle theater for
two shows on the 29th in St Louis those
are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com come the New
Year we will be adding the second leg of
this tour so if you didn't see us yet
don't fret uh other than that the reason
we are shifting is because I am going
back on the second leg of my solo tour
and I am filming a special in December
at the Vic Theater in Chicago Chicago
and Chicago's surrounding greater
metropolitan area I chose you come out
and support your boy
um leading up to that I will be at the
Hartford Funny Bone in August I will be
at the Syracuse Funny Bone in September
I will be at the there was another Funny
Bone in there and I don't remember uh
Albany the Albany Funny Bone in August
as well and then we're doing Bowling
Green Kentucky Cincinnati Ohio Toledo uh
Wilkes bar bear I never know guys I'm
sorry in Pennsylvania Wilmington
Delaware uh Macon Georgia Savannah
Georgia Athens Georgia Peoria Illinois
Rockford Illinois Cedar Rapids Iowa
Springfield Illinois and then I'm doing
a very special one-night warm-up show
right before the special in Elkhart
Indiana at the Lerner Theater those
tickets if not yet are going to be on
sale very soon at savocano comedy.com
pay attention to my socials because I'm
going to Tweet all the pre-sale stuff to
get the best tickets first uh that's
pretty much it check out my merch and
check out the podcast merch go to
samville kind of comedy.com uh Jokers
are starting up again season 10 the
second half of that Thursday nights at
10 on TBS and True TV I love you I will
see you on the road I'm very excited
what I typically do is
the stuff that I underline the day that
you know I underlined the next day I go
back before I start reading that the the
10 more pages I read just the underlying
stuff the stuff I made the notes I don't
read it all just the stuff that I deemed
important and then I start the New Path
and I do it another pass yeah and I've
been realizing like that has set me up
for like a good uh a really really good
kind of day where I feel accomplished
right away and then I you know hit the
gym or whatever else I can do but but I
but I'm also been very forgiving of
myself lately where if I John Steinbeck
has a quote he said oh now that you know
you can't be perfect go be great so
meaning like there's been a lot of times
where I would probably just wrote up
John Steinbeck I was literally about to
say the last book I met read was Of Mice
and Men in 1989. John Steinbeck East of
Eden but that's not true so so stop
I think the other one is um I don't know
I forgot so but anyway so I've been
doing that and I've been noticing that
like when you're a bit more forgiving on
yourself like there's been a couple of
days where like I want to really hit the
gym hard whatever but I don't my body
hurts and I just stretch just stretch
and I feel I'm so much better I'm I'm at
a point in my life my body and my mind
is at a point of now where I think I've
gotten old enough where I'm kind of just
accept like fully from a from a uh
nature level just accept that I am who I
am and I'm just like I'm gonna truly
trust my gut and follow my passions and
just try if I don't want to do it I'm
just not going to do it kind of thing
and go only trying to follow what I want
to do and again it's only been two three
weeks but I've it's been really
beneficial oh and another big thing
immediately if if you don't have a
backyard go outside if you can I get
sunlight even if it's cloudy sunlight in
my eyes the first five minutes of me
waking up five times minutes I get it I
walk around my yard or sometimes I walk
down the block because they uh Andrew
said sunlight on the face just kicks in
your body's natural yeah abilities that
we suppress a lot by staying Inside by
drinking coffee too much so it's not
even like um you're doing anything
extraordinary you're doing what your
body is designed to do so and I've had a
and oh I've been taking cold showers too
not the whole time just the last 10
seconds that's all I could stomach right
now is I've been churning it fully cold
as cold as I can and I just take 10
breaths through it but it hurts but my
friend was like listen 10 breaths is
going to turn into 15 breaths in the
course of a week and then before you
know it in the course of a six months
you're gonna be breathing through the
whole culture you're gonna be I could go
in the Titanic right now and get them no
100 could you do that I could do that if
they're taking up cold showers what
happens you get out and you're like a
little bit like have you ever brushed
your skin no okay okay you got dead skin
cells yeah but you're also stimulating
the circulation
so a buddy that I used to work with gave
me a Christmas I stimulate my
circulation another way yeah it's a
different way it's basically a like a
brush a body brush on the end of a stick
but it also comes off so you can hold it
in your hand okay and you just sweep up
all toward your heart on your whole body
so this way is down this way is up you
do your legs your arms dude it takes off
dead cells but it stimulates your body
your body tingles and you literally feel
an immediate rush from it what about if
we do this we do a live hey babe we take
off our dead skin cells people in the
front row get this get a little bag when
you buy a ticket you get a little bag of
our skin
what do you think of that that's a nice
incentive it costs five dollars more to
sit in the front but the price of that
is you get a little like a dime bag that
you would sell weed in of our skin yeah
it's like our version of selling the
Jarred Parts yes what do you think of
that that's a live hey babe let us know
write in the comments let us know if
you'd be willing to pay for little bags
of our dead skin yeah for the front row
of the show do it I would do it I would
I want you to do this because if you're
really taking cold showers I do you do
it before the shower I think but I
usually end up doing it after the shower
okay but I just defeat the perp I don't
know all I know is that I don't know
technology invigorated I think you're
gonna say invincible well that a little
bit but like I I haven't done it in a
while I should do it again I forgot
about it do you take a cold shower you
can't you you've told me many times you
can't get in a pool unless it's heated
you've I've heard you say that multiple
times I spent my whole life getting into
freezing cold pools and now that they
invented the heating system I really try
and stick clear of cold if you ever had
a pool in your house you best if you bet
your ass it's heated it's gonna be all
right that Lisa it'll never go below 85
it'll probably live at around 88. would
you would you be the guy that keeps the
heated pool on in the winter
if you keep the pool 12 months if I
could do that I would I mean you know
not all of us have DJ khaled's Money
he does make money but I would love to
have a heater pool all year round I
gotta be honest with you though as a guy
who now has a house with a pool yeah I'm
realizing very quickly I'm not a house
guy I'm not a pool guy my family are not
House people and we're not pool people
I I thought you've been loving the house
and loving the pool listen I'm I'm happy
to be where I'm at I'm happy to have
stability sure I'm happy for my kids to
have structure when you say you're not a
pool guy it's like you don't you don't
you don't you don't utilize it we don't
utilize it it's a lot to maintain even
though I have a great pool guy shout out
Jim the pool guy good guy you kids
aren't doing kitchen you can't open this
in that [__] they aren't they are but
I've but what I think would be better is
if we because we have because when you
have it there you tend to not use it so
much you know the kids don't go in the
pool that much this is the guy that has
their clothes on their treadmill
whatever because it just becomes it's
right there and you don't and you don't
do it sure what I think would be better
is if we had days where we took the
children to the pool it's like having a
birthday party or a party at your house
house is so much more difficult than
going to a place to have the party all
you do is go there do the party they
clean everything up you come home that's
what I'm thinking with the pool it's
like when the pool's at my house then
the party's at my house the cleanup's at
my house the dirty towels are at my
house the white floors are at my house
you know the all these how this this
house I have to maintain is at my house
I'm maintaining my own house at my house
and and I don't want to do that I I'm in
a part I'm an apartment guy I am in a
I'm a guy who wants to have an apartment
yeah I mean and I want my children to be
in the apartment with me and Jasmine to
be in the apartment with me and Jasmine
was very anti this but she is now slowly
and I've asked her I've asked her wait
did you flip again
you flipped now let's flip this house
you flip to anti-house again I flipped
to anti-house again no you didn't it's
so you didn't wait wait you a house
and then you said to me I was a big
house guy yeah and then you said to me I
need to go back to where I open my door
and it's right in front of me I need
yeah I I need to I can't be in a place
like this yes and then you came back
then I came back it was only a couple
weeks ago right and you said I don't
know what I was talking about I thought
about it more I completely am back on
board with in my house and we're on
right I want to where I went and now are
you telling me now that you are now
second guessing keeping the house I'm
telling you that I'm actively looking
for apartments in Tribeca no you're not
I swear to God I swear to God I'm
sweating right now wait but what
happened from the last time I spoke to
you that Jasmine you've come around and
that you do appreciate living in the
house in a Suburban neighborhood I
started reeling daily stomach and I'm
following I'm following my energy I'm
following my passions and the kids and
the kids that's a double flip that's a
that's a I I might flip two more times
but by next week okay so do you feel
you're gonna move to an apartment in the
city
I'm thinking it's on the table try backs
not try back up but I was kidding about
that but I gotta tell you I just looked
at apartments in Brooklyn what are you
thinking tell me I think do they have
pools for the square footage for what
you're going to get for your money is
just not worth it but I'm not about but
see here's the thing I the square
footage is not what I'm paying for
anymore it used to be that's what my
value was how much feet am I getting for
the money for me now the money is not
attached to the square footage it's
attached to the location of where it is
both should be true but I'm just saying
you have a family of five right so
you're gonna need at least a certain
amount of square footage right so you
have to shop from that square for the
job no matter what it is oh yeah a 2000
if it's modest a 2 000 square foot even
two thousand square feet is relatively
small for a family of five right in the
city you're talking astronomical yeah I
mean I went into buildings that they
maxed out the nice newer buildings even
they they maxed out like 2 300 square
feet Max and you're talking millions of
dollars for these places yeah yeah yeah
no it it it might be a pipe dream it
might be everything you could do it I'm
just saying like you're gonna pay I just
found that it was a good exercise for me
to go look at these apartments I did it
for a couple days I went to like six
seven places and I was like now my
money's gonna go further like if I could
just put it into like a home instead of
an apartment no or at least in the city
because the reason I wanted to come here
same thing you want I want the energy I
want the access right I want the
location right you're starting to feel
low energy on Staten Island yeah I want
the location but even where you live
I mean I'm all right I'm never on Staten
Island I'm never there but are you are
the guy are you comfortable in the place
where you live now that you could stay
there for 20 years like you you don't
need change no I don't think I like my
place now but I don't think I could stay
there for 20 years I think I'm growing
out of it and I think I need a bigger
you're kind of over it yeah I want my
how I I a apartment life it's I've done
my whole life I'm in my 40s you know
like I want the Oasis now right now I
want my I want a yard and I want it to
be like
my own literal oh like you know I wanted
to be I don't see other I just want to
be in a wall of green and private and
quiet you know I want that but the
opposite but does that do you so you
want to open up your front door and have
nobody around you you want to drive to
the you know like I'm on acreage acres
and Acres but you don't mind driving to
the bagel store you don't mind that I
will you don't mind that you don't have
that you can't walk out the door but I
will sacrifice I've never had my own
yard I never had my own pool nothing I
never had a pool nothing I just want
that see I'm thinking though I
understand because I never had it either
and I and again there are certain guys
or people that are House people there
they love this I'm the person when I
look at the pool what I see is just
liabilities yeah what I see is what I
see is my kids can have an accident
there their friends can have accidents
there I have to clean this I have to
maintain this I have to pay for this I
have to close it I have to open it I
don't want it near me I want to go to it
for three hours and then leave it wow so
you have the pool you've attained it yes
and now you're like eh I could do
without it and it's not a thing like but
when you say I have to close it I ever
open I have to clean it you don't do
that no I'm paying to do that so you're
saying I don't want to even pay to do
that I don't even like my house with all
the the you know there's four bedrooms
there it's like I don't it's too much
space like it's it's just things to
collect it's things to get dirty it's
things to maintain I'm like I'd rather
live a lot more minimal I'd rather live
so much more minimal yeah so and I think
I understand what you're saying that you
got a family of five so you need a
certain amount of square footage but I
think the children would adjust we would
take the children out more we take them
to the park we'd get them walking we get
them even with me I have a whole you
know I have a swing set for the kids in
the back and a pool for them and it's
beautiful to have three children it's
beautiful that they play with each other
but they only ever really play with each
other they have play dates where when I
took them to the park I took him to the
park on Staten Island for Father's Day
uh a couple of weeks ago we went to a
park in Great Kills
um it was awesome it was like a it was
like a marine animals inspired Park it's
like a big shark face did you go to the
it was on the water it's like right by
the Marina Cafe Gateway National Park is
where you went with the Gateway no I
don't think it was I know Gateway I know
Gateway it's the marina no but it was on
the other side Wolf's Pond Park no
um no it was uh it was a it was uh yeah
let me see I might I might have it in my
thing it was a um
it was a marine like marine life marine
life Park
um I don't know I love a good Marina
though Seaside Wildlife Seaside Wildlife
Nature Park Tennyson Drive Staten Island
I've never heard of that yeah it was
down the back street it was awesome how
did you find it I Googled top 10 parks
in Staten Island really and that was
number one that was number two and and
so but what happened was the playground
they're going wild the kids they were
with 50 other kids and they had so much
fun they get that at school right they
do but I want them I want them
to always have a better life than me
that's what you know I think so you
don't think you could drive them to the
park you'd rather I can but but you do
it less because if they have swings
outside they wind up on their tablets
you know it's very difficult for me to
get my 10 000 steps a day I can't do it
I gotta walk back and forth in front of
the house like my father
and and then I keep setting off the
motion sensor light I don't want to do
it I rather
I'm not saying the city the city might
be bald but you know a neighborhood
where like we're just out in the it's
it's a thing when you're living there
because even where you live it's like
you've still got community and all that
but like where I live and I have a great
Community I have wonderful wonderful
neighbors but you are just kind of up
there you kind of just out on a hill
depending on the swung back in the other
direction yes and I don't know I may
lose you
maybe the the part of Staten Island I'm
in okay if I could go to a like I'd
rather go to a place where you know you
could um like on Forest Avenue over
there you couldn't you got those
beautiful houses you can walk to the
store yeah just go get in the flowish
and get lost yeah with me I'm like I can
walk through beautiful the beautiful
mansions and all that that you see you
know if you walk down a few blocks see
these really beautiful houses that's
nice but it's like you see there's no
flow there it's the same thing where
people change right the houses always
look the same but if I'm walking down
the block I'm going to see different
people all the time and that'll make it
now I'm making the same block look way
different because there's different
energy from the people yeah and I want
to get my 10 000 steps a day and I can't
get it yeah it's all about 10 000 steps
a day yeah Seneca the great stoic
philosopher Seneca said the greatest you
go for walks walks is what clears the
mind going for walks I I don't even have
sidewalks where I am I can't go for a
walk or get hit by a car or a deer I
don't like it babe relax
Seneca would say to relax you will the
dichotomy of control you'll find the
sidewalk I've been going for a walk
every single morning now at 9 00 a.m for
the last four or five months every day
seven a week yeah well if I'm home so
you set the alarm at 9am and you go for
the wall I'm up at seven okay and then
like at nine I just go you go yeah any
direction any any I have the same route
is it with the flow just you're going
with the flow I just go with the one I
just I have a whole round I go and I go
back and I go back and I I go anywhere
from two to six or eight reps back and
forth back and forth back and forth and
I had the steps too so that's why you
get 10 000 a day I rarely get 10 000 but
that's because I rarely am not working
yeah I mean if I'm off off I can get the
10th I get 10 12. like today I am now
planning my walks like today we're gonna
finish hey babe and then I have some
stuff to do so I'm just gonna walk I'm
just gonna walk around the city I like
it let me see what my steps are today
my steps today oh yeah
forty five one one one one five eleven
Five One Eleven
so five so you're already halfway to ten
thousand yeah because you want you
walked I walked this morning because you
walked off the I walked this morning and
then I walked uh here from the boat and
you did your 9 A.M walk yeah there you
go so you're already halfway there five
one one yeah but you still got you're
going to the Cure tonight you're going
to the concert you're gonna get ten
thousand today okay you might get ten
thousand do laps around the arena I will
say though I love I love the walk so
much that I like look forward to it
every day and I don't want to miss it
and when it rains it's like such a
bummer but you do it anyway
um I've done drizzle right but can you
yourself an ice umbrella I love a good
umbrella oh I love a good umbrella one
that is not flimsy and that will open up
and give you enough coverage and you
know it's always going to be there for
you no let me tell you something about
you not only do you love a good umbrella
you have the best rain gear you've got
yellow like rubber ducky jackets you
have rubber rain boots you really you
you have you have the attire of a
fisherman yeah you're a fisherman attire
yes I I don't have the body of a
fisherman but I have the fisherman of
time you have the body of a fish
really scaly and smooth and shine yes
you breathe out right out of the sides
this Show sponsored by better help it's
very easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you babe how's
your work life balance is what I want to
ask you it's not the best and and and
the all well it wasn't the best but then
it got better when I signed on with
better help because they just have the
you take this quiz you know this little
questionnaire form and they match you up
with the licensed therapist that is
tailored for you that helps you you can
change the therapy center anytime if you
don't like them you got to think about
that like I got to think about reflect
on how much time you spend on yourself
in a given week and if it's not enough
you need to make a change you can make a
change and then you do this all from the
comfort of your own home you know it's
all done entirely entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible
suited to your schedule and right now if
you've got a betterhelp.com that's help
betterhelp.com hey babe you're gonna get
10 off your first month
babe butcher box you know what the meat
in the Box the meat in my mouth that's
what I like I love butcher box
I use butcherbox religiously ever since
they have come on to this podcast and I
have butcher box High Quality Meats in
my freezer right now July 4th having a
big barbecue all the meat from butcher
box because they first of all what they
do is they send you a box
of all different meats you got the
everything's they got 100 grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken pork raise
crate free wild caught Seafood they got
the best high Quality Meats everything's
strongly raised is the thing everything
no antibiotics no added hormones it's a
little bit right to your doorstep it's
always free shipping yeah you can curate
your own box or pick from their boxes
you could pause or cancel anytime it is
the best you don't have to worry about
meat shopping now you go to the grocery
sign up today at butcherbox.com hey babe
use the code hey babe to get flank steak
for free in every box for three months
plus twenty dollars off your first order
butcher special deal they're giving us
butcher box I like that butcherbox.com
hey babe use the code hey babe to claim
this deal it's a great deal what do you
think about those fishermen like over in
like you know in in Asia that spear fish
and like live off the freshly caught
fish every day and they're like they
live to like 150 years old I think I
think because they don't have uh they
there's no chemicals in the fish I think
they're I I will say one thousand
percent and I don't know if they're
tracking it they get 10 000 steps a day
they probably get ten thousand but they
don't even try they don't even probably
have a Fitbit do you think that you
could spear a fish no never no I don't
think I would I think what would most
likely happen is I'd throw that Spirit
I'd spear my own foot yeah you're
absolutely I'd spear myself to the ocean
floor just like the Titanic thing well
me and you go on a helicopter tour
and uh there's some issues and it lands
in the middle of a a valley okay okay
and then the guy says I could be back
you guys stay here I'll be back I'll get
help and then me and you were there for
a couple days we realized oh my God
we're gonna have to like live off the
land like bad girls right how how are we
eating first I kill you immediately you
kill me kill you immediately and I make
a fire and I start with the Cavs
do we go fish first are we hunting an
animal I mean let's just say I want to
go fish we have a lighter like right and
we can we can cook something like where
where is our first food coming from I
think I'm gonna my first attempt is
gonna be the fish because the fish a
fish is almost an animal that doesn't
even it's not even alive to me even when
it is alive like I'm almost like I could
just get a raw deal I could cut it open
and eat it while it's looking at me
because I'm almost like it doesn't have
a soul it's not because it's so opposite
of what I live like yeah Souls fish I
don't think
what has a soul animals do you have
souls I think animals have salts mammals
but not fish do you think Souls so
there's a soul in a mammal it's a
kangaroo is that a mammal yeah it's a
marsupial soups okay of a hippo is that
a mammal
I don't know what a hippo is a woman
this philosopher is saying even plants
have souls well well then that makes it
then what are you supposed to eat you
think you get reincarnated as a plant
you can you can well you can I have some
my friends there's a plant right now no
no you can you can get put into compost
and and be grown as a plant now that's
awesome you can get uh when you pass you
can choose to be put into like a mulch
what would you choose do you want to do
that I
I only heard about it for the first time
about a week ago or two and I thought
like wow that's insane I want them to
make me into like plaster
and then like construct a house with me
you want to come back as like a recite
like a water bottle yeah
warm and good human composting well
that's what it's gotten to I think
because you know recompost the first
human composting colors which is clever
so yes we compose I like it the first
human I like hosting a funeral home in
the US is now open for business wow
that's that's wild now that's Casey Jost
here he is
um you go in that thing and there's a
process and then you come out and then
they plant you get planted in the yard
not for you though up as a tree not for
you I've only just come around to
Cremation recently myself but uh what
was I getting at
we were talking about fish and animals
yeah okay about having salts so yeah so
you don't think fish have do fish feel
pain
I can't imagine they do but I know
science is going to tell me that they do
but I can't see how it's possible no
if I mean I guess they don't have brains
they have a central nervous system and
no brains like what animals that don't
have brains fish don't have a brain
right no so are you telling me that a
fish is operating solely solely on
biological Instinct yep so there's no
there's nothing more than just like
biology going on then just instinctual
like like like there's nothing going on
in a fish other than yeah instinctively
eating and instinctively swimming yeah
and sickly avoiding things are going to
pray yeah
that's most animals they're not doing
anything but going off their Instinct
nor biologists have long recognized that
fish have nervous systems that
comprehend
and respond to pain
fish like higher vertebrates have
neurotransmitters such as endorphins
that release that relieves suffering the
only reason for their nervousness and to
produce these painkillers is to
alleviate pain
that sucks I don't think so I just don't
think I don't I I don't believe it I'm I
don't I don't think that they feel
anything look at them when they're being
killed or when they're out in the their
eyes don't move they don't blink I don't
think their eyes move though as as just
a normal time if you can't blink you
don't have a soul that's what I'll say
yeah if you don't blink you don't have a
soul I mean a fish man is either the one
the blind people don't have salt fish is
not a good life right no I'm good you
just spear a blind person
yeah
um no I'm kidding um could we catch a
fish with our hands and hit it with a
rock yeah I think we didn't like start a
fight no no no fighter no I'd catch the
fish without no if you catch the fish
with the hands just let it on the floor
don't let it get back to the water it'll
die yeah but it runs out when do we when
did we I know man I just we really are
numb to that like fisherman come take a
throne on the thing and things like
yeah to all of his friends he's like
Jesus Christ he's suffocating yeah
somebody do something yeah we just do it
like it's nothing I know today there was
a worm uh in my uh living room there was
like you know it's like a grass back
there there was a worm and I like gently
like took it on like a piece of paper
towel and I went and then I showed
delicate and I was like I'm doing such a
good deed and then you know I'm staying
whatever six feet I I had the paper
towel here and I went like that and
shook it off and it I watched it land on
the floor outside of my house and not
move at all I because I dropped it from
what would be the equivalent of like the
Empire State Building
and I didn't even think of it I didn't
even think of it
and it was dead on the floor it was
didn't move for about five minutes do
you not kill bugs like do you like it I
try not to kill it I try not to kill
anything this bugs I'll kill immediately
yeah what are they and there's bugs I I
why do ladybugs get such a pass
PR PR and yeah it's all PR it's it's
it's the movie that you know they're the
polka dots yes the name cutesy I'll tell
you what I'll kill immediately roach
done roach I'll kill a roach and it's
family roach in front of its family yeah
and then tell the family I'm saving you
go tell the others I'll kill the roaches
I don't play games play games I don't
kill spiders I don't kill ants I kill
I'll kill him outs I don't no I can't
kill a mouse did you guys see the
ladybug found in a colonoscopy what
[Music]
how is that possible are you showing me
a ladybug resting on someone's
not in so much they got into they got
they did how do you get in past State
they've burrowed through their anus no
I did not feel of ladybug burrowing
through your animals also I don't know
anuses don't really have openings
how's that ladybug getting in
I don't know how the hell that ladybug's
getting in the old-fashioned way you
imagine you're a ladybug and you were
living your ladybug life and then you
find yourself in someone's ass in a 59
year old man's ass
the details just keep coming in
and then that
is alive
wow and so that bugs family is like we
don't know they don't even know his fate
and they don't know that he's in an
animal dead somewhere like dying to I
kill uh what else you kill on sight a
wasp maybe well I'm I'm afraid that I'd
exacerbate it's you know I'm afraid that
I would piss it off but like oh if it
lands right here and it's like just
chilling I'm gonna kill it because I'm
not gonna get stung no who else you
killing oh on site I always wanted to do
that this home be like yo on site bro
what site on site on site so I'm talking
to the bugs right now the bugs that
would kill on site on site
um uh a beetle
I'd kill a beetle they're in the
Cockroach family I'd kill him yeah
beetles are
no thanks they don't they're not
in any way warm I feel like they burrow
into your skin I don't need it they're
hard I don't need a beetle yeah yeah the
Beetles I don't like them
um I don't like grasshopper I'm all
right with do you know the praying
mantis did you know did we talk about
this at the Beatles
is a play
on Beat the word beat b-e-a-t isn't it
right so they're the beat like the beat
right not the b-e-e-t-l-e I never really
remember it across my mind but they
spell it with an A and I think that they
just mean like yeah
yeah I don't um I don't uh The Beatles
are one band inspired by the the
Contemporary band name the crickets so
they they were like oh let's we do Beats
because it's music now it's like just
it's a pun right it's a corny ass pun
right and it's the the most famous band
ever do you know a lot of Beatles songs
probably all of them yeah
I'm guessing then just a value back to
you I'm guessing how many real songs do
you think the only one that I know for
sure I swear to God no no no no no no no
you know I'm going on record and say you
know
20 BL songs at least the only one I know
for absolute sure is Let It Go
the other ones I I let it be let it be
yeah let it go it's from Frozen
Let It Go Let It Go
let it be let it be is the only one that
I know you're crazy I know that there's
an album called we say Hey Jude
but how to take you go Hey Jude don't be
afraid take a sad song Yes okay yes that
that I know you know we all live in the
Yellow Submarine I know that there's an
album like a paperback right you you
probably you know you know Twist and
Shout
hey Twisted
Shake It Up that's the Beatles Stan chat
yeah okay so that one I know for sure
yeah you know all the oldies right and I
saw her standing when she was just 17
what yes
17 yikes yep I need somebody help not
just anybody help me if you can I'm
feeling that okay so you know when I
know a lot I know the old yeah but I
know them from commercials they're big
Beetle songs big on commercials sure wow
uh yesterday
love was such an easy game to play yes
that one I know my trouble right see I
just didn't know that these were the
Beatles right I'm telling you this
Happiness is a Warm God I Wanna Hold
Your Hand that one I know all right you
know Happiness is a Warm now you won't
know Happiness is a Warm Gun but you
know that one you know Blackberry
blackbird singing
that one all right uh let's keep it
going
when I'm will you still need me will you
see me when I'm 64. that one I don't
know really no uh Can't Buy Me Love
yeah all right so these some of these I
know but you know all the old ones I'm
trying to like see like like a little
bit later like uh
like The White Album Fixing a Hole is
one is the name of a song Fixing a Hole
I'm not sure right now but you know
probably all of uh Sergeant Sergeant
Pepper
with Sergeant Peppers Lonely Hearts Club
Band that one I don't know I've heard of
Sergeant Pepper's all right all right
uh Abbey Road I mean all right all right
anyway do the Beatles do they do any do
they do any more like uh more this guy
on all the way on the left looks like
Mike Feeney
yes do they do they are all of them dead
besides McCartney
yes They're All Dead He's the last one
no no no well no Ringo is alive but what
but um George Harrison and uh uh
John Lennon John Lennon but will
McCartney and Ringo ever do a I don't
know I saw McCartney play the Barclays
when uh about
did he do Hey Jude he did everything he
played for like three hours I cried
three times he did all the Beatles songs
it was just unbelievable to hear that
those songs coming from him like they're
attached to moments and world events and
all that stuff it's just wild to be like
in this moment in time I am hearing this
guy sing this song that has affected
every person on the plane like you know
did they have like Holograms and stuff
of John Lennon they didn't but hopefully
one day do you cry at a lot of concerts
which concert
how many times have you cried at
concerts probably plenty
really depending on uh yeah
depending on the act or the song I might
not cry the whole concert but I might
cry for one song like I'll get
goosebumps I won't cry though cry well
celebratory cry well well seeing him was
very moving and he sings you sing
something like yes like Let It Be Like
You know you sing those songs that and
it's just like it kind of resonates with
you I don't think I was like weeping but
I just mean like I welled up in a tear
fell like will you cry at art at Art
yeah yeah physical art yeah like in the
Museum of Natural History I don't think
I could be taking that like that I don't
think I'll cry at Art per se
unless it's imagery like moving image
like if I said something like I don't
know have I ever created art
I'll tell you I cried out to the movie
Boyhood
interesting is that the one with the
same actor for 20 years yeah why'd you
cry at that it was so moving right it
just was it was very like it was to
watch that movie
it it it just captured something that I
think on another movie's ever captured
it was so it just was so real I was on a
flight once with Ethan Hawke I was
sitting right behind him yeah
and we were going from New York to LA
and that was on like a Monday and then
seven days later I was on a flight
sitting right in front of Ethan Hawke
going from La back to New York no way
yeah and when we got we're getting off
the plane I said to him I said oh I was
on the flight with you out here and I'm
on the phone with you coming back and he
goes what a world
no way I swear to God that's what he
said he goes what a world and we got off
the fly like what was he saying he
wasn't being a dick he was saying
facetiously or being a dick I don't know
he just said what a world that was his
comment back I didn't mind it elevated
with him one time and I was there was
like eight people in the elevator but I
was with the seven
you know like so it was like him and
like maybe one other guy everybody on
the elevator I was with and then we so
we were talking and he was standing on
the corner and then while we were
talking someone goes oh my God is that
Ethan Hawk and like they said it low but
we were in the elevator and then the
elevator opened he's like yes it is and
he just walked out
yeah it's fine yeah I I think he's I'm a
big fan yeah I like this guy have you
ever cried at like art or a movie or a
piece of media
um um
I cried at Captain Phillips for some
reason really I don't know movies
right commercials that's not that's
nothing literally nothing yeah nothing
you know you can't I can't watch
Undercover Boss I can't watch oh it's so
touching uh when I get when the guy she
yelled to move the bus out of the way
and they'll give her the house oh yeah I
would cry at that instantly
um I cry at uh
I I one time I cried at a queer eye
episode you did yeah it was very it was
very nice we had a little queer eye man
yeah yeah but I I cried up I cried up I
cried I caught it a voice to men
um voiced in my mind
I cried at a Boyz II Men in Vegas okay
the end of the road the end of the road
but then they sing one about their moms
oh mama you know that got me that might
have been like I might have had like a
cocktail or whatever but I don't know
maybe I didn't but I knew I was gonna
Cry For Mama the one with the mama right
and as soon as they said Mama I just
started crying started crying yeah the
last probably not into the road unless I
really let myself go start thinking
about [__] but Mama
the last time I think I cried like that
in public was when um I went to the New
York football club like the soccer team
that played at Yankee Stadium Bernie
Williams who was my favorite baseball
player played the National Anthem with
his guitar and I started to cry I
started to like start to I started to
like well up because I I can't believe
I'm watching him play the national
anthem and then I met him and then I met
him like in the third or fourth inning
and you know he went back he went into
his suite after like they you know I met
him and I started hysterical crying into
Jasmine's chest
like on The Concourse at Yankee Stadium
okay because you met you met someone
that you admired so much that I had a
connection to from my childhood yeah
that's I it happened so this last
weekend we were on the road and I think
I was in
I forget where I said maybe maybe in KC
it was uh and we call it I call this
this 11 year old kid I called him on
stage he was couldn't stop crying like
it's that happened sometimes when we
meet people I'm just like you don't
really need to cry like I'm literally
not worth crying over at all like a
normal person there's nothing special
really here I appreciate you crying I
try to make him not cry I cried after
this is embarrassing I cried after you
know this is very embarrassing it was 20
years ago okay it was exactly 20 years
ago I went out to LA to perform with
like improv Olympic or something like
that and I I told you the story and I
might have mentioned this but I went I
was with gato and my buddy Brian Lynch
she's a screenwriter we go we go to this
place the Velvet Margarita
for a drink
uh Joe tells me the last time was last
two times I was here I saw Vince Vaughn
now in 2003 Joe and I were writing
screenplays and we were trying to like
make movies and stuff um and so I was
very into that world and a movie that
affected me among others pretty deeply
but just because it was like it felt
attainable with swingers it came out in
96 yep they did it on a shoestring
budget they did it in LA with friends
local places it just connected with me
at that time I had just recently went
through like a very bad breakup and
that's what he was doing in the movie
The Scene they hung out at was kind of
like the scene that I hung out at that
time it just resonated with me so uh I
was in that sure enough we go there and
the guy walks Invincible walks in with
John Favreau Ron Livingston
Vince wants 35th birthday at the time it
was and I'm like oh my God it's fast I
told you this story but anyway I didn't
know what to do I had no money and I
sent over I told Vince I sent him a
happy birthday I want to get you a drink
for everyone at your table I was going
to Max my credit card out I had no money
and uh he said I can't I can't accept
that it's so sweet about I can't accept
that but please allow me to buy you a
drink and so I was like I felt weird but
I was like all right my friend's like
get the drink and just post them or
something so I got like a kettle and
soda and I raised it up and they all
raised their glasses I said thanks so
much that's awesome I did the drink I
have the glass I saved it I stole it
yeah it's in my kitchen right now but
and then at the end they all stood up
and I was like I'm not gonna bother when
they stood up we were kind of leaving
and then like they made eye contact and
then I started just talking to John
Favreau at the other table and he
started he started an improv he starts
talking about that and we start talking
a little bit he's being very polite
generous talking to me for two like
three four minutes and then I left and
when I left I went out to call my
girlfriend to tell her what just
happened and I as I was telling her I
got emotional and cried yeah because at
that time he I just looked up to him so
so much do you know him now have you met
him through the stuff I know Vince now
yeah and I never told Vince she tell him
that's well I felt weird about it and we
know that he's listening it's so funny
yeah he
yeah I should tell him about it he is
good friends with Peter Billingsley
Peter Billingsley played Ralphie in A
Christmas Story among many things since
then but they they have their production
company together he's one of his right
hand guys yeah and Vince used to do the
Wild West Comedy Festival Nashville for
like four or five years straight and I
was a part of it every single year they
invited us back so I got to know them
and Peter Billingsley oddly enough is in
my other I mean swingers and like his
favorite movies like is in the top five
for me and so is I think Christmas story
is my favorite movie of all time and
I've never I've known Peter Billingsley
now for almost 10 years and I've never
told him that either
I don't know they probably hear it all
the time I didn't want to like
I didn't want to be that person
know them as is yeah give people their
flowers man exactly yeah I've I've never
seen Christmas story that is my my that
is my Snapple up there and filled with
water anyway sorry ADHD you've never
seen A Christmas Story never seen a
Christmas let's play it 24 hours
straight every year I've never seen it
once yes never seen it once you've never
turned on the television I've never seen
a Christmas story you don't know
anything about it zero wow bud I gotta
tell you it's fantastic I'm going home
I'm gonna listen to The Beatles and
watch a Christmas story in July yeah I'm
telling you dude it's real what's your
favorite Christmas movie Santa Claus
with Tim Allen okay that's that's okay I
wouldn't I wouldn't [__] on you for that
all right not home alone
oh yeah Home Alone
Home Alone 2 though more than one no I I
love everything in New York it was a
carbon copy I love it I love Christmas
in New York I love the fact that it was
in New York but it was it it was just
something it just was trying to cut it
was the same exact movie what's your
favorite Woody Allen movie
what's one I gotta want what's next in
the list for me if I'm I've watched five
in a row what's next
I would I would really tell you to watch
Annie Hall yeah yeah it's I it hell
holds up and it was like ahead of its
time it's funny yeah this can see in the
movie is like um it's him and Diane
Keaton and you know it's a it's a
romantic comedy but like he the whole
movie you hear his thoughts and you hear
everyone's you hear her in his
thought so he'll say something and then
you'll hear like what he's thinking and
that I don't know if that device was
used prior to that got it I've seen it
since well that's why I like the
concepts of it like that's why I like
midnight in Paris you ever seen Midnight
in Paris he's also Manhattan murder
mystery right uh that I think that was a
good one too but Midnight in Paris I
like because it's like you know it's
like that whole idea of nostalgia where
like you you know think like you're like
oh man I wish I could go back to New
York in the 90s and then you go back
there and you realize that the people in
the 90s wanted to go back they were like
things were so much better in the 50s
and that's what the movie is it's like
they go back a hundred years in Paris
and then the people 100 years ago in
Paris after he gets to know them are
like yeah but you know things were good
in the 1700s and it like keeps going and
it's like it's how do you feel to this
day it's kind of like an idea of like
you're you just got to be happy with
your present be friendly with your
present because it's like you're always
going to want to go back in time our
brains go into this nostalgic mode yeah
I guess it's safer
I I would like to see that do you know
that he I don't know if he still does he
played every single week for like 30
years he played Jazz clarinet Uptown
what yeah every week you just go see him
play jazz clarinet he played every when
he was as famous as Woody Allen he for
the last 30 years he still does he'll be
doing it can you throw that in bed see
Woody Allen he's playing the Jazz
clarinet
Jazz clarinet uptown
I don't know how to play one instrument
he had like a residency
interesting an evening with Woody
yeah but he did it every week for a very
long time
interesting where did Woody Allen play
the clarinet in New York City
oh it's a Carlisle yep that's it to
Carlisle hotel that's Uptown yeah yeah
the car you've been in that hotel ever
um once fun nice it's a nice place I
don't know many New York hotels I know I
know uh I know of a couple of uh
a friend
I can't even say it on air but yeah I
can't say it um
Bullets Over Broadway was fun Jennifer
Tilly Love Jennifer Tilly JT yeah the
real JT what was that movie she was in
with like Gina Gershon where they tied
each other up and [__]
wasn't it like a real a real sultry
humdinger
oh Bullets Over Broadway challenge bound
Maybe
bound maybe is that a Woody Allen
no I know that but the one bound that
he's saying
bound that's the name of it I just
remember and it's a Woody Allen movie I
don't know if it's a Woody Allen but
them two right there they get hot and
heavy
and fast and loose love it lesbians this
has been hey babe
[Laughter]
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]